le reste de l'actualité c'est d'abord
les suite de l'évasion de jacques
mesrine
hier matin l'homme qui avait écrit dans
son livre on ne s'évade pas de la santé
et pourtant ce soir encore dans la
nature de donc bien fallu qu'il dispose
l'important de complicité et c'est tout
cela que l'enquêté c'est d'établir en ce
moment enquête centrée autour du
témoignage de m giletti l'une de ses
avocates
dernière personne à l'avoir vu quelques
minutes avant son évasion
la prolongation de la garde à vue de m
gillet qui a d'ailleurs été obtenu du
parquet par les policiers on se retourne
et 34 heures de cavale ce soir pour
jacques mesrine et françois bès depuis
leur évasion de la santé hier matin par
ce mur d'enceinte de 15 mètres de
hauteur à l'angle de la rue jean dolent
et de la rue de la santé depuis la
chasse au gros gibier se poursuit pour
les hommes du quai des orfèvres bar
fréquenté par la pègre à paris en
banlieue hôtel louche repères de crues
en aucune trace des deux fugitifs
les anti gang et les enquêteurs de la
brigade de répression du banditisme sont
pour l'instant bredouilles ils ont passé
aujourd'hui au crible la voiture de la
fuite
une et revint retrouvait boulevard
lefebvre les perquisitions effectuées à
montreuil au domicile de christiane
giletti l'avocate de mesrine et à son
cabinet du 16e arrondissement n'ont
apporté aucun élément nouveau utile à
lenquête en prologation garde à vue au
quai des orfèvres
christiane giletti va passer sa deuxième
nuit au dépôt et jacques mesrine lui en
liberté
voilà donc